so you want to be normal so you just
want to be like
everybody else that roams the world not
knowing the power that's in them
i think i feel feel fear quite strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly there is one
habit
that i have adopted in the last three
years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five habits
that are holding you back
and how to get rid of them enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one you watch netflix with david goggins
do you ever have a day where you just
think i can't be asked to do anything
i'm not going for a run i'm not
stretching
i'm doing nothing every day yeah
you say you have the thought but you
don't have the day every day don't ever
let yourself have a day when you just
watch netflix
never because you can't show netflix i'm
haughty no i can't do it
i can't do it there may be some days i
get up with poopy pants
and i'm like you know what man this man
like what am i training for
yeah i have no race in the docket why am
i having this
this such a structured life why and i'm
like you know what
i'm good i'm done i retire every day
yeah i'm done with this and i sit around
and say okay
and then this is my thought process so
you want to be normal
so you just want to be like everybody
else that roams the world
not knowing the power that's in them
being fine with being mediocre
you want to go back to who you were huh
david i don't like
that man you have that conversation with
yourself every day
not every day it's those bad days yeah
it's those bad days i see a whole bunch
of people walking around out here
who have no idea how talented they truly
are and i'm talking about
talent like some god-given ability
talent that sometimes you have to hone
you have to work on and you get to
harness yourself
and they just walk around this on their
phones just clueless to
how powerful they are habit number two
you let fear
stop you with elon musk you are
unusually fearless and
willing to go in the face of other
people telling you something is crazy
and i know a lot of
pretty crazy people you still stand out
uh where does that come from or how do
you think about
making a decision when everyone tells
you this is a crazy idea or where do you
get the internal strength to do that
well first of all i'd say i actually
think i i think i feel feel fear quite
strongly
um so it's not as though i just have the
absence of fear i've
i feel it quite strongly um but
there are just times when something is
important enough
you believe in it enough that you you do
it in spite of the fear
so speaking of important things like
people shouldn't think i i i
i should if people should think well i
feel fear about this and therefore i
shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to
definitely something mentally wrong if
you didn't feel fear
um so you just feel it and let the
importance of it
drive you to do it anyway yeah you know
actually something that can be helpful
is fatalism
uh to some degree if you just if you
just accept the probabilities
um then that diminishes fear
uh so um starting spacex i thought the
odds of success were less than 10
percent
um and i just accepted that actually
probably
i would just lose lose everything um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died maybe some other company
could pick up the baton and move
and keep moving it forward um so that
would still do some good
um yeah same with tesla i thought the
odds of a car company succeeding were
extremely low habit number three you're
procrastinating with brendan burchard
you're more likely to do something if
you have
already prepared and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already
prepared and stepped it through what
does that mean it means
if you want to not procrastinate on
monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
project plan i know it's not sexy
please don't make fun of me right now
it's not sexy i know it's not sexy
and it will change your life forever the
day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists
that is one element of project planning
but i want a bigger picture i want you
to be thinking about
the big projects that you have coming up
and i want you to have
written out these steps that it's going
to take the big steps that we'll take
to accomplish this project and this
project and this project with a timeline
for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny if listen to
this
if your mind can't see completion
if your mind cannot see completion
meaning you don't know the path
you don't have clarity on the path to
fulfill or complete something
if your mind can't see the steps
your heart will ask to pause
if your mind can't see
the project through the completion your
heart will ask to pause
even if you're the most passionate dream
oriented amazing high performer in the
world
but you yank away someone's clarity you
know
no goals no growth no clarity no change
and so if you find yourself
procrastinating
it might not even you might be like but
brandon i hate myself i procrastinate
and i even know the next three things i
should do i go not enough
knowing your next three steps is not
enough
your mind needs to see all the steps
through to completion
and that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here are the big
key activities the big buckets of
activities
that would have to happen to get it done
here's the timelines those big buckets
have to happen
okay then these big buckets of
activities those have been broken down
into tasks
and then into ultimately daily to do's
and if we don't have that like it's just
hard to act when you don't have a
complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating let me give you a
metaphor
you know uh they've timed people about
how long it takes them
to complete a puzzle so if i show up at
your house
and i give you a big puzzle box and
there's 400 pieces in it
and we set it out on your table
and we watch how long different time
periods takes to complete it
you know the fastest most productive
time in which people are putting puzzles
together
the last 20 percent if you've ever done
a puzzle right
you might walk by it three four times
for a couple weeks you don't do anything
you put a few pieces together
but as soon as the picture becomes a
little more clear guess what you do
you hunker down and you complete it
don't you
that's what's going on with
procrastination even if you see the
first couple pieces
it's just like if you can't see where
it's going
your heart will go pause i'm unsure
i'm scared i don't know what to do
that's just how we think right that part
of our brain that is trying to protect
us
that part of our heart that says i want
to do good i want to care for other
people
and do things with excellence all of a
sudden those are compromised
when we don't do the most basic thing so
if there's an important project you've
been procrastinating in
do yourself the greatest gift i can give
you today
and that is tonight sit down with your
journal and step it all the way out
even if you have to make it up even if
you're like i'm not sure this is
actually the big activities
it it's not about having the perfect
project plan
it's having one that is completed with
at least the knowledge you know now
because then your brain go okay let's
get into this and keep making this thing
better
but your brain won't get into it if you
haven't project planned
so this is really important what i do to
avoid
procrastination each week is every
single sunday for me that's my sunday
review days sunday work days
i'll sit down and i'll literally step
through the entire week of all the major
things on my
email or on my to-do list i'll think
about the bigger projects
and i'll just kind of step it all the
way through and guess what
i enter the week more engaged
more joyous and confident because i know
what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not
lots of worry or it's not you know lots
of randomness
it's you haven't seen it through yet
all right my friend evan carmichael's
book listen humans are built to serve
some people are built to serve the world
others
want to serve the 25 people closest to
them but in either case humans are built
to serve so if you're not happy right
now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide for that
habit number four you're on your phone
first thing in the morning with mel
robbins
so other than the five-second rule there
is one
habit that i have adopted in the last
three years
that has fundamentally changed me as a
business person
and it has also changed my ability to
manage
my emotions so i don't get hijacked
i do not allow my phone
in the bedroom i know the research
deloitte just did a study based on phone
use alone and 33 percent of people
are reading emails in the middle of the
night i know that if you
go to bed and the phone is right next to
you right so you go to bed
because you need your phone you know
somebody might need you and you sleep
you know if this is right here and it's
not closed and the blue light is on
they've done studies where you have
people at a table and the researcher
will put their phone
on the table not even my phone the
researcher's phone and the brain lights
up like crazy
just with the presence of a phone the
research around the phone and sleep
is so stunning that if you were to adopt
one radical thing today other than the
five-second rule try
putting your phone outside your bedroom
turn off
so you don't hear it tell people who
need to reach you to call you my kids i
have a kid in college a kid who's
you know high school kid in middle
school if there's an emergency
call me there is nothing happening on
your phone at two o'clock in the morning
that's important but if you allow
yourself to become a tool
of this this is supposed to be your tool
for selling
your tool for communicating and we're
all becoming the tool here's the other
thing common sense wise that i want you
to understand you wake up
the alarm goes off what do you do
so you're not even vertical
and you're reading emails and what is in
these emails
other people's crap so if you don't have
boundaries with this puppy
it's going to impact sleep it's going to
impact how much money you make it's
going to impact how much self-control
you have
and so when i put this thing outside the
bedroom
and i wake up i walk over to where the
phone is it's plugged into my bathroom i
turn it off i don't look at it yet
i give myself five minutes five minutes
before i tune into the world
to actually tune in up here and say
what's the one thing i'm going to get
done today
that really matters to me if you're the
kind of person that feels like you don't
have control over your day that your day
gets hijacked that you can't get to the
priorities that you're always behind the
ball
this one planning thing will change your
life no phone in the bedroom
turn it off when the alarm goes off five
minutes five lousy minutes
five lousy minutes before you tune in to
the rest of the world
and if you've got the kind of job where
you've got to check it get up 10 minutes
earlier
you have control over this stuff and it
is so important that you take it
seriously now because
you're living at the slowest moment of
your entire life
and habit number five the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is you talk too much with simon sinek
nelson mandela is a particularly special
case study
in the leadership world because he is
universally regarded
as a great leader you can take other
personalities and depending on the
nation you go to we have different
opinions about other personalities but
nelson mandela
across the world is universally regarded
as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day how did you
learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings and he remembers two
things
when his father would meet with other
elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two his father was always
the last to speak you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen
i would say that you need to learn to be
the last to speak
i see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders
will walk into a room and say here's the
problem here's what i think but i'm
interested in your opinion let's go
around the room
it's too late the skill to hold your
opinions to yourself until everyone has
spoken
does two things one it gives everybody
else the feeling
that they have been heard it gives
everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed and
two you get the benefit of hearing what
everybody else has to think before you
render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself
if you agree with somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is
ask questions so that you can understand
what they mean
and why they have the opinion that they
have you must understand
from where they are speaking why they
have the opinion they have
not just what they are saying and at the
end
you will get your turn it sounds
easy it's not practice being the last to
speak
that's what nelson mandela did now i've
got a really special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below write down your single biggest
takeaway as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
the reason why you are not chasing your
big dream is because you're afraid that
it's going to fail
you're afraid that it's not going to
work and what people will say about you
and what you will think about yourself
but what's the alternative it's sitting
on your idea for years
never taking your shot because you're
afraid and living the rest of your life
in regret
knowing that you had an opportunity but
were too afraid to take it
the way to not have regrets is to be
always taking action to as soon as you
get an idea go do something about it i
had a great podcast with my friend mark
drager
a couple weeks ago a month ago or so
where
he was asking me about regret and i used
to always tell this story of
imagine you have a hangnail how much
that hurts and it's all you can think
about when you have a hangnail but if
somebody punches you in the arm you
don't feel the hangnail anymore because
this hurts more right you focus on what
hurts more and suddenly this one doesn't
hurt as much
that's how i would use regret i would
always think about
whatever pain that i'm in right now this
thing that i want to do
but i'm afraid i would imagine that this
thing is going to be the best thing of
all time that
this video i'm going to make this speech
i'm going to give this clan i'm going to
meet
is going to be the best of all time and
if i don't do it i'm going to regret it
for the rest of my life for decades i'm
going to regret not taking action
and so the pain of doing the thing
is the hang nail and the future pain of
regret for decades is the punch to the
arm
and so it inflicts so much pain on me
that then i have to go off and do that
thing
and i use that for
over a decade over a decade
that's the lens through which i made
decisions and saw the world
but for the past two years i haven't
done that at all i haven't talked about
it
i haven't done it for myself because i
talk about the things that i live
and i'm thinking why why don't i do that
anymore why don't i
use future regret to fuel me
and i found this because i'm always
taking action because as soon as i get
an idea i do something
and so i don't judge the idea i don't
say why me
i don't ponder on the idea i don't i
don't just default to strategizing and
thinking i don't think why did i come up
with this why am i thinking about this i
just do it
you get an idea you go off and do it and
that's been my mindset for the past
year and a half two years and as a
result
the breakthrough was you don't live with
regret
if you're always taking action on the
ideas that you have
you don't live with regret you might
regret some of the things you end up
doing
but most of the things that you regret
and other things done as the action's
undone
not undone not taken the action's not
taken
you don't regret the things that you did
you get the things that you didn't do
that's most people right there may be a
couple things that you regret that you
did but for the most part
it's the things that you are too afraid
to do that you regret for the rest of
your life
and so if you're constantly doing if
you're constantly taking action if
you're always jumping
then you don't have regrets and it's
been an interesting way
that i now see the world and hopefully
you can learn from as soon as you get an
idea you go off and you do something you
do that you won't have any regrets
[Music]
if you want to change your life in 30
days for free check the link right below
me and if you want to know the five
habits that will transform your life
check the video right here next to me
continue to believe
i'll see you there